bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi 2 su gta indovinate con chi sono e
molto difficile indovinare
niente ho capito anzi ha detto allora
libertà da green già tare l'intro ecco
la lega ma che veicolo siamo già allora
soprattutto non è tanto le che veicolo
usiamo e perché siamo in piscina dove
andare non lo è però a me non importa
siamo non siamo su una rampa ma siamo su
una gara stunt chiamo che diavolo esce
fuori come ricorda non c'è famiglia
preso una macchina che non dovevo messa
tu ma che ho preso laga cosa avendo non
ti vedo la proto
no io e te mi ama pro ma cos'è che
succeda abbiamo tutti la stessa mano tu
hai l'ottusa è diversa loro io sono
diversa non vale rifacciamo sbandata e
vabbè ma vince vinto stefani il problema
è che sai cosa vuoi da me ma salutari ma
non è vero perché dobbiamo sempre far
staccare stesso scusa ma io adesso vado
lento di proposito ma scusami ma la mia
macchina di legge penso di cavolo ma non
solamente periodo non credono tanto mi
batto uguale non ci credo vede niente
oddio ma levate virus si capiva bene la
gente in mezzo è no vabbè ragazze ma di
stare in giro a milano ma ti vuoi
togliere santo è va beh guarda mai non
c'è parole ti ho messo diritto deve
essere prima che di testa raccoglie zio
mature fa da malaga aspetta c'è un ponte
invisibile confusi con quelli
ma basta corre dritti ma sega perché sta
andando avanti per caso però va bene ok
a posto forse ci abbiamo fatto ma cosa
vedo io nella mia visuale baci ma cosa
sto vedendo cosa sto vedendo non raga
pazzesco capisce niente
ma cosa sto vedendo levato dove vado
e che ne so io sto correndo solo dritto
ma io non so che stai andando dritto io
non provo altro fabrizio basta co sto
per andare dritto finisce io ho vinto la
gara ma come finito la gara
qui c'e una gara ma come un fenomeno che
sta succedendo in corso edilizia non ha
fatto nulla
uno come thriller the hottest e fregare
me l'hai fatta tu hai pagato tizio dove
come si fa qua ma questa era ubriaco che
andava creato sicuramente però mio dio
fermarci davanti ve lo vuoi superare si
concorso con questa macchina che in
confronto a una panda quelle classe
pazzo e quale si è schiantato prima
della fine è pazzo ha preso del padre ti
prego fanno una metti un altra roba
perché anche cosa dire ai ragazzi siamo
su un'altra gara che teoricamente
dovrebbe essere un pelo più lunga ma
almeno abbiamo tutti la stessa macchina
vi ringrazio che mi fate sempre partire
dietro no ma veramente ragazzi esporti
guarda sull'air moscow fermo navale vai
è vero ma vale sa perché adesso che fare
lo sborone che riesce a vincere lo
stesso
no non vinco tranquilla siamo su una
rampa di prima o poi proprio di
carbonara 46 degna chi è dietro di me
che vivo a tutti e due march
prevalentemente sta arrivando alla
leggete la gara era tenente ve lo
abbiamo visto abbastanza impegnandola
che ho dentro detto l'ho detto l'ho
detto l'ho detto l'ho detto l'ho detto
l'ho detto e tutto a pochi di socio mi
sono sbagliato e allora a quell'altro
adesso ti prendo è certo sono io io
potevo avere controllo al momento adesso
arrivo i belli our vezza era un click
pate e la gara ecco la vedi line al
momento della vera arrivino a marigliano
che in quel momento è il momento in cui
via di pillo che succede è una roba un
po la roba avendo la vedo non mi ha
tenuto un omaggio no anch'io
ok hai detto tu non è per niente faccio
la mia occasione porca vacca no
non ha mantenuto perfetto e sempre
occasione ragazzi no mm di un meno ma
perché i ragazzi di fini diventa
veramente difficile ma tra i soci cosa
volevi dire scusa
ha detto tua mia tua lingua rampe
proprio bello è quello ma siamo qui 20
minuti siamo ce l'ha fatta per primo
colpo ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta
manovra fatta sei volte non è vero e
vabbè dopo ancora un casino ora che è
pieno di roba così e ce ne sono ancora
poi dopo aver fatto non è finita
non ce la faccio mi arrendo mamma mia
ragazzi è bellissimo e riesco a rimanere
in piedi
yes ho fatto io ma dopo se io ho finito
il pezzo di rampe e allora si faccia mai
vinto nasce di renzo laconi giri dava un
giro
e credo che sia tutto come prima si è
allora sì let's go
devo arrivarci non è stato per
interfacce quindi arrivarci di nuovo non
sarà facile proporre che la miseria
passo si erano delirio alla seconda è la
seconda al casinò questi tra yard non so
se tale si sente al sicuro in questo
nome che è sicuro io facciamo i giochi
di sci adesso sono ricaduto dove sono
caduto prima ok sony vuole rampe i
ragazzi al convegno per una volta
stavolta attento di farla giusta perché
sbagliarla subito io la faccio il primo
colpo da farci sentire
l'ho fatta domanda giusta di sbagliarci
la seconda per rompere la seconda la
prendo sempre sbagliato all'inizio però
prendo check point cos'ha fatto
non so se consigliarla sbagliata no è un
mezzo sbagliato ok no non l'ho preso
dieci sono l'ho fatto no finora però non
sarebbe legato al traguardo è finito ma
noi per me è finito appena fatta da
a volte non arrivato non è da me però
non arrivato da march non mi dissocio
anch'io guarderà arrivato a destra non
recupera vediamo se ci posso credere
non ci credo l'avevo preso io sto
guardando marco provava un errore e di
un errore un errore si meriti popoli
march ragazzi basta perché siamo già
troppo emozioni tutte in una per una
volta non ha vinto step quindi
incredibile incredibile si era sì perché
una volta che vinco una volta ho vinto
basta non lo dirò mai più niente ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto ischia di hulk
arrivarci step passate e siete i vostri
commenti
perché ha dato vincitore stesso i punti
delle due gare ma che i punti nelle due
gare ma basta questo paga giochi per
essere vicino ai ragazzi
[Musica]